Imagine, for a moment, that you were given
the opportunity to become the most powerful
person in your country.
To get there, all you need to do is betray
the very man who made you who you are.
Would you demure, step back, say “thanks,
but no thanks”?
Or would you grab that opportunity with both
hands?
Nearly half a century ago, one man in Chile
made the decision to betray everything for
his own glory.
His name was Augusto Pinochet.
The eldest son of middle class Catholics,
Pinochet spent the first fifty eight years
of his life wallowing in obscurity, only to
suddenly rise to infamy.
The driving force of the 1973 coup that deposed
Chile’s democratically elected president,
Pinochet oversaw a reign of terror almost
unmatched on the continent.
Yet he was also a leader who counted icons
like Margaret Thatcher among his closest friends.
Join us today as we delve into the murky life
of the man who boosted Chile’s economy,
even as he eviscerated its soul.
The Donkey
In the lives of evil men, there are often
telling details from their early years that
show the monsters they will become.
The serial killer who tortures animals; the
future dictator who delights in suffering.
In the early life Augusto Pinochet Ugarte,
however, there was nothing.
Nothing to suggest this young boy would one
day drown his nation in a sea of blood.
Born on November 25, 1915 in Chile’s great
port city of Valparaiso, baby Augusto came
from a solidly middle class background.
His father, Augusto Snr., was a local customs
official descended from French settlers, while
his mother, Avelina, was deeply religious.
Speaking of Avelina, the child Pinochet was
something of a mommy’s boy.
When most of the family moved out to the countryside,
leaving Avelina in Valparaiso, Pinochet demanded
to stay with her.
Still, it’s not like this familial separation
constituted “hardship.”
Pinochet’s early life was remarkably privileged.
He was even enrolled in Sagrados Corazones
private school, then one of Chile’s most
elite institutions.
Not that this stopped other boys from picking
on him.
As a teenager, the boy was, by his own admission,
woefully weak.
He had a loud, braying laugh that earned him
the nickname “donkey”.
He was also a pretty terrible student.
One of the only things teenage Pinochet was
really good at was art, netting himself school
prizes for his paintings.
But if Pinochet ever seriously flirted with
being an artist, the dream didn’t last long.
By the time he graduated, the boy had decided
he was going to be a soldier.
This was easier said than done.
Pinochet’s father, Augusto Snr., was determined
his oldest son become a doctor.
But Pinochet had an ace up his sleeve.
Avelina doted on her eldest son as intensely
as Pinochet revered her.
When the boy said he wanted to be a soldier,
Avelina made damn sure a soldier was what
he became.
It was a rocky road.
The military actually rejected his application
twice.
But finally, in 1933, the boy and his mother’s
persistence paid off.
Pinochet was accepted to the War Academy in
Santiago.
The remarkable thing about Pinochet’s time
there is just how unremarkable it was.
By the time Pinochet graduated with a commission
in the infantry, WWII was already looming.
But since Chile decided to sit the war out
– only symbolically declaring war on Nazi
Germany during the endgame – Pinochet spent
his best fighting years kicking his heels
in Santiago.
Still, even way down south in Chile, WWII
had a potent effect.
The role of the USSR in fascism’s defeat
galvanized Communist parties in Latin America.
Governments responded by cracking down on
them, sometimes using extreme measures.
By 1948, the Chilean government was keeping
Communists in internment camps.
It was while overseeing one of these camps
that Pinochet had his first run-in with the
Doctor.
That year, an upstart Socialist senator decided
to make a personal inspection of the internment
camps, to see if the Communists were being
treated well.
When he arrived at Pinochet’s camp, the
man who’d once been known as the Donkey
threatened to shoot the senator.
That senator’s name was Doctor Salvador
Allende.
Neither the Doctor nor the Donkey knew it
yet, but their fates were already inextricably
linked.
The Doctor
The story of Augusto Pinochet isn’t the
story of one life so much as it is of two
lives.
The life of Pinochet himself… and the life
of Dr. Salvador Allende.
Born on June 26, 1908, the Doctor’s early
life was eerily similar to the Donkey’s.
Like Pinochet, Allende was likely born in
the Chilean port of Valparaiso – although
we’ve seen at least one source claim he
was really born in the capital, Santiago.
What’s certainly true is that Allende also
came from a large, middle class family with
a devoutly religious matriarch.
Like Pinochet, Allende’s father wanted him
to become a doctor.
But while Pinochet’s formative experiences
would be shaped by the military, Allende’s
came from a very different direction.
Juan Demarchi is one of those figures who
exist on the sidelines of history, yet still
manage to exert an outsized pull on events.
An Italian immigrant cobbler, Demarchi lived
on the same street as the Allendes.
But he had another identity he liked to keep
secret.
Demarchi was a committed anarchist.
At some point in Allende’s childhood, the
boy and the Italian cobbler became friends.
Demarchi wound up teaching the teenager about
class oppression, worker’s rights, and the
failings of capitalism.
Although Allende never fell for anarchism’s
charms, under Demarchi’s sway he became
a committed socialist.
It was Allende who, in 1933, cofounded Chile’s
first Socialist party.
Allende who, in 1945, became one of its first
elected Senators.
It was while in office that he had his first
run in with Pinochet.
Remember?
In that camp where Pinochet threatened to
shoot him?
Not that the Doctor dwelled much on the encounter.
He was too busy running for president.
In Chile’s 1952 election, Allende finished
an impressive… dead last.
He was even temporarily booted out his own
party for his abysmal campaign!
But you can’t keep a good socialist down
and, in 1958, Allende ran again.
This time, he almost won.
The result was painfully close.
The Conservative candidate squeaked home with
a mere 33,000 more votes than Allende.
Allende’s team came away convinced that,
next time, they would win.
Unfortunately, they hadn’t counted on Fidel
Castro.
On January 1, 1959, Fidel Castro overthrew
Cuba’s government and installed a Communist
dictatorship.
Suddenly, the whole of Latin America was in
the grip of a red scare, and trying to win
elections as a socialist was like trying to
win Mr. Universe when you look like a Biographics
scriptwriter.
Allende’s third presidential run, in 1964,
was a failure.
The Doctor’s public admiration of Castro
left him a very distant second.
Really, that should have been the end of it.
Allende had lost three elections now, get
the message already, dude!
But Allende didn’t get the message.
Like Sisyphus marching his boulder up the
hill, Allende entered the 1970 election determined
to win.
Against all the odds, he did.
By 1970, Chile’s economy was struggling.
There was widespread discontent, a hunger
for change.
To top it all off, the rightwing parties split
the vote, leaving the way open for a leftwing
challenger.
The result was Allende winning 36.6 percent
of the vote, a tiny mandate, but more than
anyone else.
The shock victory set alarm bells ringing
across the Americas.
In Washington, DC, the Nixon administration
demanded the CIA stop this upstart Marxist
from taking the presidency.
Instead, they handed Allende the keys to the
Chilean White House.
On October 25, 1970, a bunch of CIA-backed
rightwing paramilitaries tried to kidnap a
pro-Allende Chilean general, likely to clear
the way for a coup.
But they bungled the operation, killing the
general and rallying the Chilean public, the
Chilean establishment, even the Chilean military
to Allende’s side.
Suddenly, the Chilean Congress’s attempts
to block Allende’s inauguration were dead
in the water.
On November 5, 1970, Doctor Salvador Allende
was sworn in as Chile’s president; the first
democratically-elected Marxist head of state
in Latin American history.
Barely was the inauguration ceremony over
than the CIA began plotting to make sure he
was also the last.
The Battle for Chile
OK, so we’re up to 1970 now, a full 22 years
since we last saw Pinochet, guarding an internment
camp and threatening to shoot senators.
That’s a heck of a long time.
What’s the old donkey been up to all these
years?
The answer is: nothing.
We can’t stress enough how the most intriguing
part of Pinochet’s life is how utterly destined
for obscurity he seemed to be.
In 1970, he was a 55 year old career army
man whose only contribution to world history
had been once threatening to shoot the future
president of Chile.
The one thing that pointed towards his future
notoriety was how, in 1971, he was placed
in charge of the Santiago army garrison.
Y’know, the ideal post to have if you ever
wanted to send an army marching on the Chilean
capital.
Not that Pinochet currently had any reason
to do so.
Nor would’ve he ever had, were it not for
the third key player in our game.
The CIA.
Up in Washington, DC, the Nixon Whitehouse
was tearing its hair out at Allende’s election.
The CIA was ordered to “make the (Chilean)
economy scream.”
American money flowed into rightwing Chilean
propaganda.
Into sabotage attempts.
Into aborted coups.
To be fair, Allende was a scary prospect for
US and Chilean elites.
With barely a third of the vote, he was nationalizing
everything in sight.
Still, every move Allende made was in line
with the Chilean constitution.
A socialist he may have been; a burgeoning
tyrant he was not.
Keep that in mind as his tragic, bloody story
plays out.
By 1972, Allende’s government was widely
unpopular.
In an attempt to shore up support, the Socialist
president invited military men into his cabinet.
Among them was Carlos Prats.
The leading constitutionalist in the Chilean
Army, Prats wasn’t happy with Allende, but
he was even less happy with the idea the army
should remove him from power.
So long as Prats was running the army, there
was no chance of a coup in Chile.
We know this because on 29 June, 1973, a bunch
of disaffected officers tried to stage one.
Known as the Tanquetazo because most of those
involved attacked the President’s residence
– La Moneda – in tanks, the coup was a
monumental failure.
Nobody flocked to the plotters’ banner.
When Pinochet got wind, he made sure his garrison
came out on Allende’s side.
There’s actually footage from this era that
appeared in the documentary The Battle of
Chile of Salvador Allende striding down the
streets of Santiago in the coup’s immediate
aftermath, Augusto Pinochet loyally at his
side.
It was this very moment that convinced Carlos
Prats that Pinochet was on the Constitutionalist
side.
So when Prats resigned a month later, he made
sure Pinochet replaced him.
And so it was that, on August 22, 1973, Augusto
Pinochet became head of the Chilean armed
forces.
When most Chileans heard this, they were kinda
like “what?
That donkey?”
Even Pinochet’s wife thought he was joking.
But it was no joke.
Prats had just promoted the most unremarkable
man in Chile to a position of remarkable power.
It was a decision that would soon destroy
him.
Democracy Burns
Many years later, long after Salvador Allende
was dead, Pinochet would boast that he’d
been plotting a coup against the Socialist
for more than a year.
But other sources paint a picture not of a
cunning man waiting for his chance, but a
nobody who accidentally wound up heading a
conspiracy.
On September 8, Chile’s other generals confronted
Pinochet.
While no record exists of the conversation,
it seems they basically said “look, we’re
gonna overthrow Allende, and you too if you
stand in our way.
Now, are you in or out?”
It turned out Pinochet was way in.
On September 11, 1973, the residents of Santiago
awoke to the earthshaking thud of explosions.
Across the capital, military fighter jets
were bombing La Moneda, each pass causing
new plumes of smoke to spiral up towards the
clear blue sky.
Imagine watching on TV as the Whitehouse is
consumed by flames, knowing those burning
it are American soldiers.
That’s what millions of Chileans felt that
fateful morning.
In a great historical irony, Allende’s first
reaction as the coup got underway was to mutter
"I wonder what they have done with poor Pinochet”.
He had no way of knowing that the last army
man he thought was loyal was directing the
bombs raining down around him.
Allende’s last stand is today legendary.
Armed with a Kalashnikov given to him by Fidel
Castro, he and his entourage managed to hold
off the Chilean army for hours.
But there was only one way this could ever
end.
As soldiers swarmed the flaming ruins of La
Moneda, Doctor Salvador Allende shot himself
through the head.
He was 65.
Out on the streets of Santiago, leftists,
protestors, artists and intellectuals were
all being rounded up and marched to the internment
camps that were springing up across the city.
Most notoriously, this included the National
Stadium, where dissidents were tortured in
locker rooms before being dragged out onto
the pitch and shot through the head.
At the same time, announcements were going
out that Chile was now under the control of
a four man military junta, headed by General
Pinochet.
As the shockwaves of the coup spread out,
the old Constitutionalist general Carlos Prats
slipped out of Santiago for exile in Argentina.
Yet the man who had made Pinochet wouldn’t
be able to outrun his erstwhile friend for
long.
On September 30, 1974, a car bomb killed Prats
and his wife in Buenos Aires.
It’s thought Pinochet himself ordered the
assassination.
Back in Santiago, the junta instituted a reign
of repression.
Political parties were banned.
Censorship put in place.
All leftist media shut down.
Around 80,000 people were arrested.
Another 200,000 were forced into exile.
Not that the junta itself lasted long.
On June 27, 1974, just ten months after the
coup, Pinochet used his clout with the Army
to force the other junta leaders to step aside.
In their place, he had himself elevated to
Supreme Chief of the Nation.
The long tradition of democratic rule in Chile
were now at an end.
For the next 16 years, the Donkey would rule
his nation as its undisputed king.
Days of Terror
From the get-go, the regime of Augusto Pinochet
marked itself out with its sheer brutality.
One of Pinochet’s first acts was to order
a mop up operation against leftists who still
remained in Chile.
Known as the Caravan of Death, this unit traveled
the vast length of Chile’s deserts and wastelands,
flying into small towns and executing anyone
who opposed military rule.
All told, 97 Chileans were murdered by the
Caravan.
In some cases, they were flown far out over
the Pacific in helicopters and simply hurled
to their fates.
Meanwhile, those who’d been arrested in
the aftermath of the coup were funneled into
concentration camps.
Out in the dry Atacama Desert, old saltpeter
works were turned into centers where leftists
were worked to death, or executed by being
blown up with dynamite.
Similar camps appeared in the frozen wastes
of Patagonia.
But the worst of the new regime’s torture
centers was right in the capital.
The Villa Grimaldi was once a grand old colonial
house.
Now it became a monument to mankind’s worst
impulses.
At the still-awful, but normal end of the
scale, prisoners there were suffocated to
the point of death and then released.
At the nastier end, the teenage daughters
of regime critics were kidnapped and used
as practice for soldiers learning the ropes
of electroshock torture.
At the most deranged end of all, female prisoners
were forced to have intercourse with animals
while their guards watched and laughed.
It was a Grand Guignol of horror.
Nor was it confined just to Chile.
In November, 1975, Pinochet’s secret police
– the DINA – made contact with the dictatorships
of Brazil, Paraguay, and Uruguay – later
including Argentina after the March 1976 military
coup.
Together, they came up with something called
Operation Condor.
Its goal was to assassinate every single leftist
on the continent.
The idea was that the DINA would pass information
on Chilean dissidents to the other Condor
nations, and vise versa.
They would then “disappear” one another’s
enemies.
For the 60,000 people killed by Condor, that
meant being dropped into deep lakes or rivers,
or shot and buried in remote mass graves no-one
would ever find.
Sometimes, though, it meant a more dramatic
end.
On September 21, 1976, Salvador Allende’s
former Foreign Minister, Orlando Letelier,
got into his car in Washington, DC, where
he’d been living in exile since the coup.
With him was a 25-year old US citizen, Ronni
Moffitt.
At 09:30 am, a bomb concealed in the car exploded,
killing both occupants.
Even the American capital seemingly wasn’t
safe from the DINA’s reach.
Yet, this terror only strengthened Pinochet’s
grip on power.
As the 1980s dawned, the Chilean tyrant rammed
through a new constitution giving himself
8 year terms as president.
Come 1988, there would be a Yes or No referendum
on whether Pinochet could keep power.
Until then, he would be the one man ruler
of Chile.
Chile’s dictatorship was here to stay.
The Two “Miracles”
By this point, you may be wondering why such
a perverse regime wasn’t an international
pariah.
The reasons can be summed up in a single phrase:
“the miracle of Chile.”
That was the name given by the free market
economist Milton Friedman to what happened
in Chile after Pinochet seized power.
Under successive governments, Chile’s economy
had been badly struggling.
During Allende’s years in office, things
had only gotten worse – although its debatable
whether that was due to leftwing policies,
or due to the CIA constantly trying to instigate
a coup.
When Pinochet took over, he decided to try
a new route, one mapped out by the Chicago
Boys.
The Chicago Boys were native Chileans who’d
studied in Chicago under Friedman.
Suddenly elevated by the regime to key positions,
they were tasked with transforming the economy.
Transform it, they did.
In the second half of the 1970s, Chile became
a laboratory for perhaps the most extreme
free market economic policies in history.
Everything that wasn’t bolted down was privatized,
everything opened up to the market, and businesses
given unfettered access to all parts of Chilean
life.
The result was a wild rollercoaster ride that
saw both the highest inflation rate in Chile’s
history, and one of the worst one-year recessions
on record.
But, by the time 1988 arrived, the wild ride
was over.
Chile’s economy was the most stable in Latin
America.
Chile was rich.
Pinochet’s supporters still point to this
as his signature achievement.
It certainly won the regime friends, with
Margaret Thatcher openly talking of her admiration
for Pinochet.
But even here, we should sound a note of caution.
Chile today is successful, but it also has
one of the highest levels of inequality in
the world.
The Chicago Boys may have made Chile rich,
but they did so while eviscerating the poorest
in society.
Come 1988, Pinochet was riding high.
The economy was doing great, all his enemies
were dead, and he was secure in power.
So when it came time to hold that referendum
we mentioned earlier, the one on keeping Pinochet
as dictator, Pinochet went ahead and held
it.
Despite all the abuses, he thought he really
was popular.
How could the hero who’d delivered Chile
from socialism lose?
But if Pinochet thought he was a hero, Chile’s
electorate was about to prove they still saw
him as a donkey.
On October 5, 1988, the plebiscite returned
its shock result.
The pro-Pinochet side had scraped a mere 44%
of the vote.
The anti-Pinochet side had won by 12 points.
The next day, an outraged Pinochet called
his generals to his offices and declared he
would never stand down, that the vote was
a fix, that it was all a mistake.
But the generals knew something the old donkey
didn’t.
They knew the US was already piling on the
pressure, that Pinochet would have to honor
the result, or face international consequences.
One by one, they refused to back Pinochet.
Isolated, the dictator had no choice but to
publicly announce he would step down in two
years.
The next year, in 1989, the first presidential
election since 1970 was held in Chile.
The center left candidate, Patricio Aylwin,
romped home with over 55% of the vote.
Suddenly, the age of oppression was over.
When Aylwin was inaugurated on March 11, 1990,
democracy finally returned to Chile.
Of course, Pinochet didn’t just return to
civilian life.
He remained head of the armed forces, and
was later gifted not just the post “senator
for life”, but immunity from prosecution.
But if the Donkey thought he’d have an easy
retirement, he had another thing coming.
Justice At Last?
On October 17, 1998, Augusto Pinochet was
visiting London for minor surgery on his back.
Ever since he’d stepped down as Chile’s
leader, 8 long years ago, the former dictator
had grown fond of the British capital.
Thanks to Chile’s clandestine help to Britain
during the Falklands War, he thought the British
had grown fond of him, too.
Well, the British were about to give him a
rude awakening.
That day, as the 83-year old Pinochet lay
in hospital, he was arrested by officers from
London’s Met Police.
Seven days earlier, a Spanish judge known
as Baltasar Garzón had issued an international
arrest warrant for Pinochet.
Under Spanish law, serious crimes against
Spanish citizens can be charged in Spanish
courts no matter what jurisdiction they are
committed in.
Several Spanish citizens had been abducted
and tortured in Chile during the regime, and
now it was payback time.
The arrest was like a lightning bolt to the
international community.
Suddenly, the eyes of Pinochet’s many victims
were all trained on London.
We wish we could now wrap up this video with
“and then Pinochet was extradited to Madrid,
where the judge found him guilty and sentenced
him to a bazillion years in prison,” but,
sadly, that’s not what happened.
Although British Parliament ruled international
immunity did not apply in cases of torture,
the establishment still closed ranks to protect
a foreign leader.
On the Conservative side, Margaret Thatcher
made an impassioned plea for Pinochet to be
freed.
On the Labour Party side, the Home Secretary,
Jack Straw, declared Pinochet was too ill
to stand trial.
On March 3, 2000, Pinochet was wheeled onto
a plane from London to Chile, looking like
he was at death’s door.
When he touched down in Santiago, the dictator
triumphantly stood up from his wheelchair
and smugly waved at his supporters.
As is so often the case with history, the
monster had escaped unscathed.
However, there is still a postscript to this
story.
While the Spanish warrant never went anywhere,
at home in Chile, lawmakers were starting
to reassess the idea of lifetime immunity.
In 2004, a state commission on crimes of the
dictatorship dropped a shocking report that
revealed over 35,000 people had been tortured
by the regime, and over 3,000 murdered.
That same year, Chilean lawmakers lifted Pinochet’s
immunity over the Caravan of Death killings,
and the car bomb assassination of the Constitutionalist
general, Carlos Prats.
One year later, in 2005, Pinochet was placed
under house arrest.
It was days after his 90th birthday.
Over the next year, more and more allegations
came to light.
Evidence of colossal levels of embezzlement
was presented.
In 2006, Pinochet was formally charged with
kidnapping, torture, and murder.
Sadly, the stubborn donkey once again escaped
justice.
On December 10, 2006, Pinochet died of a heart
attack at his home in Santiago.
Just days earlier, he’d been told he was
fit to stand trial.
Today, the Chilean state has begun to slowly
account for the crimes committed during Pinochet’s
tenure.
Over 40,000 living victims have been identified
and provided with compensation.
Around thirteen hundred former officers and
soldiers have been tried for crimes against
humanity.
Chile may still be haunted by the shadow of
Augusto Pinochet, but at least history is
now able to judge him for the monster he was.
He may have escaped justice in his lifetime,
but Pinochet’s crimes will go down in history.